hello i'm the hotel manager and this
gentleman is my partner
the lobster presents us was a strange
reality david whose wife has broken up
with him
is sent to a hotel where he'll be turned
into an animal of his choosing
if he doesn't find a partner in his
allotted stay at the hotel now the fact
that you'll turn into an animal if you
fail to fall in love with someone during
your stay here is not something that
should upset you
or get you down but this situation isn't
the strangest element of the film
when david is asked what type of animal
he wants to be turned into if he doesn't
find a partner
he doesn't question the strange reality
of this situation now have you thought
of what animal you'd like to be if you
end up alone
yes a lobster he doesn't fight back
instead he seems passively resigned to
what is completely absurd
and it's not just david if you thought
about what animals you want to be if
you don't make it everyone around him
seems to accept this bizarre reality as
well
[Music]
excuse me
do you have the time in your ghost
lanthamosa's most
recent work the short film nimik we see
a similar
passive resignation to a completely
strange reality
excuse me do you have the time
a father meets a strange woman on the
subway that he asks for the time
she follows him home enters the home
with her own duplicate key
and begins mimicking his words and
movements tell her to get out
tell him to get out the father and in
fact the whole family
don't question how the woman got into
the house or why she's mimicking him
they might be distressed but they don't
seem surprised by this
sequence of events lanthamos doesn't
have his characters behave this way just
to create a strange effect
this response from the characters causes
the audience to
infer a larger world a world that exists
beyond simply what we see on screen one
that has
strange rules social norms and
metaphysical or physical laws that are
different from our own worlds
in lanthamosis second film dog tooth a
father constructs a false reality for
his grown children
that he's trapped at home and isolated
from the outside world
[Music]
in this alternate reality words for
things that exist
outside the family's home are redefined
to refer to things
within their home
their world has its own weird rules
norms and definitions
that don't make any sense to us as
outsiders and yet the children
blindly accept these things because it's
all they know when the oldest sibling
throws the sun's toy airplane outside
the fence
the sun doesn't try to walk out and get
it himself instead he asks the father to
use the car to pick it up
at this point in the film it hasn't been
explained that there's a rule that the
children cannot go outside the fence
but we infer the existence of that rule
because we see
the sun obeying it in the lobster nimik
and to some extent the killing of a
sacred deer
lanthamos is playing the role of the
father in dogtooth
as the director he constructs worlds
with strange norms and rules
that have an absurd logic and he reveals
those rules to us
through how the characters respect and
obey them
in dogtooth we understand that the
father has arbitrarily defined these
rules
that they can be broken but in the
lobster the killing of a sacred deer and
nimik
we don't get to see the origin of the
rules that define those film's alternate
realities
instead lanthamos imbues these worlds
with a sincerity through the use of
visual cues
like this slow zoom lobster because
lobsters live
for over 100 years are blue-blooded
like aristocrats
and stay fertile all their lives
in the killing of a sacred deer
otherwise benign interactions like
martin the young man
visiting the family gain almost a
metaphysical eeriness
through the same movement
good afternoon you must be martin that's
right
you must be anna that's right in typical
film grammar a camera movement like this
is usually used to indicate that
something of significance is happening
lanthamos unsettles us by using this
move when what's significant
about the moment isn't obvious martin
does turn out to have a sort of
metaphysical power
and on the subway in nimik this odd but
benign interaction does cause
something strange to happen in the same
way lanthamos suggests the existence of
a larger structure of rules in his
worlds
through how the characters behave even
if we don't understand or learn about
those rules
his cinematography suggests that
something significant is happening in
these moments
even if we don't understand exactly what
this approach to filming these absurd
worlds lends a sort of seriousness and
significance to the world's absurd
rules the characters in the world
respect the rules and even the film
itself
understands and projects the
significance of these occurrences
the deadpan delivery of lines extends
into
an almost deadpan delivery of the film
itself
makes watching these stories an
incredibly strange unsettling and
sometimes humorous experience
as the audience we may feel like we're
missing something why don't the
characters push back
why do they accept the absurd reality
they're inside children please
children tell your mother who the real
father is
how should we know we're just kids
don't they see its absurdity but these
characters aren't passively resigned to
the world around them because they are
apathetic and uncaring they are resigned
because they don't believe these rules
are arbitrary
then the procedure changes according to
the animal when it's chosen
that makes total sense we can see this
reflected in how the characters in the
lobster talk about people who have been
turned into animals
my mother entered the hotel but didn't
make it and was turned into a wolf
they speak about it like a death
something that is outside of their
control
the fact that they fail to even question
these rules and norms suggests that they
believe
they don't have the power to change them
that their physical or metaphysical laws
of the universe
and not just arbitrary social norms a
wolf and a penguin could never live
together
nor could a camel and a hippopotamus
that would be absurd
think about it i know you're in there
the main characters in lanthamosa's
films usually do try to push back
against the horrifying outcomes of their
strange reality
but they can only imagine doing so
within the larger framework of how their
world works
in the lobster david fights back against
being turned into an animal just because
he's single he doesn't want that outcome
but it doesn't even occur to him to
question
the basis of relationships in his world
i'm very happy
because we have a new couple they met
just two days ago but they are very much
in love and perfectly suited
they both have the same problem with
their noses they bleed quite suddenly
the fact that a couple's compatibility
is based entirely on small arbitrary
similarities
his nose doesn't really bleed on its own
he bangs it against a wall
or a piece of hardwood or something like
that he sees this
as just the way things are you two are
not suited
something inherent to the world that
cannot be rebelled against
in nimick the father pushes back he
doesn't want this woman to
invade his family and replace him but he
ultimately accepts the outcome
determined by the bizarre test
that the family conducts in the killing
of a sacred deer the family doesn't want
to slowly die
but they only fight for their individual
survival within the rules of the curse
or diagnosis that's been given them
i believe the most logical thing no
matter how harsh this may sound is to
kill a child
because we can have another child unlike
dog tooth where we see the source of the
rules
and know them to be false and arbitrary
in the lobster mimic and the killing of
the sacred deer
we don't really know who's making the
rules the characters follow
so we have to wonder are they formed by
society
the physical universe or a metaphysical
reality
this is the core of lanthamosa's
cultural and social commentary in these
films
do you understand it's metaphorical
my example it's a metaphor
i mean creating worlds with different
norms and rules ones that seem absurd to
us
he forces us to examine the norms and
rules that shape our own world
we're forced to wonder what might be
arbitrary ideas that we accept simply
because it's what we've been taught
and what society upholds as normal and
what might be
a deeper more fundamental aspect of
our world something that we truly cannot
escape
it's through this reshaping of reality
that lancimos gives us new perspectives
on family
romantic relationships the
doctor-patient relationship
and marriage redefining words or ideas
to break us out of a tired perspective
so we can glimpse what absurdities
in our own world we might be blindly
accepting
i think understanding the lobster or any
of lantermos's other bizarre works in
this category
isn't a project of understanding what
the rules are and where they came from
and why things are the way they are in
that world but of
understanding the characters
relationships to those rules
and norms and what that reflects about
our own world
if you want to watch nimik lanthimosa's
newest film the short just premiered
exclusively on mubi
thank you to mubi for collaborating on
this essay and giving me early access to
nimik and allowing me to use footage
from the short in this video
mubi is a curated streaming service
showing hand-picked films from around
the globe
right now lanthamosa's breakout film
dogtooth is also
available as part of the movie library
the work of foreign and independent
filmmakers like lanzimos are mainstays
of movies library of films
so if you want to discover more work in
this vein mubi
is an excellent way to do that you can
watch nimik dogtooth or anything else in
their library when you sign up for an
extended 30-day free trial
by using my link go to movie.com
thomasflight
that's mubi.com thomasflight
[Music]
you